A return to an apocalyptic demolition
derby wasteland. Another adventure
inside a deadly, neon video game. And
the revisitation of a Halloween classic.
All this and more await you with these
movie sequels you may not have heard about.
The first Predator film tore into theaters
in 1987, launching a whole franchise that
has endured across decades. And now, almost
inevitably, a fifth film is on the horizon.
The most recent installment, 2018's The Predator,
was hardly a critical success, currently
sitting at a dismal 33% on Rotten Tomatoes,
but it still made enough money at the
box office to justify yet another sequel.
"Never knew how much I missed this,
Dutch." "You never were that smart."
Predator 5 will be helmed by 10 Cloverfield
Lane director Dan Trachtenberg , from a script
penned by budding screenwriter Patrick Aison.
Originally, the fifth Predator film was announced
under the title Skulls, but the official
title has since been confirmed as Prey.
Each Predator installment thus far has focused
on a group of people being hunted by a race of
alien trophy hunters, and Prey seems like
it will follow in that same tradition.
This time, the story will be set 300 years in
the past and center on the Comanche Nation,
following a warrior named Naru, who
will be played by Amber Midthunder.
While the fifth Predator seemed to
hit an unforeseen snag in the form
of a lawsuit filed by the original
film's writers Jim and John Thomas,
that apparently didn't stop the
movie from moving forward. Prey
wrapped filming in September 2021, and is set
to premiere on Hulu sometime in summer 2022.
While Hocus Pocus failed to make much of a
splash when it was first released in 1993,
it has since gathered a significant
following as a Halloween staple. The
film follows a group of kids who accidentally
resurrect a trio of witches on Halloween,
three hundred years after their execution.
The sisters set about stealing the souls of
every child in Salem, unless these
intrepid heroes can stop them.
While details on the sequel film remain scarce,
original Hocus Pocus stars Bette Midler,
Kathy Najimy, and Sarah Jessica Parker are set
to return in the sequel, which will debut on
Disney+ in the fall of 2022. Some of the movie's
most notable cast members include Doug Jones,
reprising his role from the original, as well as
Tony Hale, Hannah Waddingham, and Sam Richardson.
Working from a script by Jen D'Angelo, Hocus
Pocus 2 was originally set to be directed by
Adam Shankman, but he was replaced in
2021 by comedy stalwart Anne Fletcher.
According to an official synopsis for the
film, Hocus Pocus 2 will follow three young
women as they bring the Sanderson
sisters back to modern day Salem,
forcing them to stop the three witches
from wreaking havoc in the modern world.
Before John Boyega was known for
battling the First Order in Star Wars,
he was fighting unsettling monstrous
aliens in the urban sci-fi adventure
Attack the Block. Written and directed by Joe
Cornish, the 2011 film starred Boyega as Moses,
the leader of a teenage street gang that must rid
their neighborhood of invading extraterrestrials.
The sequel will reunite Boyega and Cornish,
who's once again both writing and directing.
This time, Boyega will also
be acting as co-producer,
in addition to reprising his role as
Moses. Speaking to Deadline, Boyega said:
"It's been a decade since Attack the Block was
released, and so much has changed since then.
I'm excited to see this heightened
story return to the streets of London.
Moses has remained one of my favorite characters
to play and bringing him back is a huge honor."
Cornish echoed his enthusiasm, saying:
"I'm thrilled we're officially announcing
our return to the world of Attack the Block
on the tenth anniversary of the film's release.
I can't wait to work alongside John again,
bringing audiences an even bigger
slice of inner-city alien action."
According to Cornish, filming on Attack the Block
2 is expected to start at some point in 2022,
indicating that the movie might
premiere as early as 2023.
Within days of the simultaneous
theatrical and HBO Max release of Dune,
a sequel was officially greenlit, with
a release date set for October 20th,
2023. The decision to produce Dune: Part Two won't
come as a shock to anyone who knows the novel or
saw the first film, which ended at what seemed to
be a pretty pivotal moment in the character arc of
protagonist Paul Atreides. Dune began a sprawling
tale of feuding households, political maneuvering,
and religious intrigue, told through an
impressive ensemble cast led by Timothée Chalamet.
Of course, not all the central players in
Dune survived until the end, but those that
did are expected to reprise their roles in
the sequel. It's also a given that Zendaya,
whose character is only introduced
towards the tail-end of the original,
will be playing a much bigger role in this
installment. Also returning are director
Denis Villeneuve and composer Hans Zimmer,
the latter of whom recently joked in a tweet:
"Thank goodness I have some music left."
As for Villeneuve, the director clarified
that he considers Dune: Part Two the same
movie as Dune rather than a traditional
sequel, telling The Hollywood Reporter:
"It's not a sequel where it's another
episode or another story with the same
characters. It actually has direct
continuity to the first movie.
It's the second part of the big,
huge movie that I'm trying to do."
Unlike the original, Part Two
will not debut on HBO Max,
instead receiving an exclusive
45-day theatrical window. Apparently,
this was a "non-negotiable" point for
Villeneuve, who says that for him:
"The theatrical experience is at the
very heart of the cinematic language."
"Oh, what a day! What a lovely day!"
In 2015, Mad Max: Fury Road reinvigorated the
long-dormant Mad Max franchise, which began in
1979 with Mel Gibson in the title role. Fury Road
offered a new spin on the post-apocalyptic tale,
casting Tom Hardy as Max and shifting focus to
Charlize Theron's rage-fueled Imperator Furiosa.
Fury Road also wowed audiences and
critics alike, with many considering it
one of the best action films of all
time. A sequel, then, seemed inevitable.
Sure enough, two follow-up films are in the
works: one is a direct sequel, while the other
is a prequel centered around a younger Furiosa.
The sequel, which has been given the working
title Mad Max: The Wasteland, was reportedly
greenlit by Warner Bros. in early 2020, and will
follow Hardy's Max Rockatansky. Meanwhile, Furiosa
will bring back the title character in question,
though Theron won't be making an appearance in
the movie. Director George Miller has said that,
much as he loved Theron's performance in
Fury Road, he doesn't have enough faith
in de-aging technology to allow Theron
to reprise her role for the prequel.
Instead, the younger Furiosa will
be played by Anya Taylor-Joy,
who will be joined by MCU star Chris Hemsworth.
Emmy-winning Watchmen actor Yahya Abdul-Mateen II
was also set to star in the sequel but later
departed the project due to scheduling conflicts.
Instead, Tom Burke will be stepping into the
role originally intended for Abdul-Mateen.
Miller hasn't yet revealed who Hemsworth and Burke
will be playing in Furiosa, but the characters
have likely existed in the director's head since
before the previous film, as he and co-writer
Nick Lathouris developed origin stories for every
character while prepping Fury Road. The Wasteland
is set for release on June 23rd, 2023, while
Furiosa will tear into theaters on May 27th, 2024.
The Star Trek franchise has been a shining gem
in Paramount's crown for decades, and there are
a number of directions the popular franchise could
head next. Moving forward right now is a fourth
Star Trek film in the current series, which would
bring back the cast of 2009's Star Trek and its
sequels — minus Anton Yelchin, who was tragically
killed in an accident in 2016. The studio is also
considering Trek films from The Revenant scribe
Mark L. Smith, which was originally intended to
be directed by Quentin Tarantino, as well as
one from Fargo and Legion creator Noah Hawley.
While Hawley's project has been moved to the back
burner by Paramount, Star Trek 4 is reportedly
full steam ahead. WandaVision director Matt
Shakman has signed on to helm the project,
working off a script from Lindsey Beer and Geneva
Robertson-Dworet — making this the first Star
Trek film to be penned by women. Star Trek 4
is set to hit theaters on December 22, 2023.
Although rumor has it that a third Sherlock Holmes
film has always been part of the Warner Bros.
plan, things have been a little slow recently,
since Robert Downey Jr. has spent the past decade
anchoring the Marvel Cinematic Universe. Saving
the world every couple years is a draining gig,
and Downey's superhero commitments kept him
from being able to take on the detective
role for a third time. Now that Downey has
finally exited the MCU for good, however,
he finally has the time to team up with
Jude Law's Watson for one more case.
The third Sherlock Holmes film will be
helmed by Rocketman director Dexter Fletcher,
a departure from the first two films, which were
both directed by Guy Ritchie. Meanwhile, the
script comes from Narcos creator Chris Brancato.
While Sherlock Holmes 3 was originally scheduled
to release on Christmas Day, 2020, it's since
been delayed due to the uncertainty caused by the
COVID-19 pandemic. After having its theatrical
release bumped from 2020 to December 21,
2021, Fletcher remarked in the fall of 2020 that
the sequel is sitting in limbo until things get
back on track. While the film obviously
won't make its Christmas 2021 release,
at the moment, it's suspected that Sherlock
Holmes 3 will hit theaters sometime in 2022.
Disney's live-action reimaginings of their
animated classics have proven to be a home
run at the box office, and the live-action
Aladdin was no exception, bringing in
over $1 billion globally. So it comes as
no surprise that it's getting a follow-up,
although this one likely won't be modeled directly
off the animated version of the animated sequel.
Few details are known about the Aladdin
sequel, although stars Will Smith,
Mena Massoud, and Naomi Scott are all expected
to reprise their respective roles as the Genie,
Aladdin, and Jasmine. Guy Ritchie is also
expected to return to the director's chair,
working off a script from John Gatins
and Andrea Berloff. As for the plot,
it's still very much an unknown, although it's
possible that the sequel could take the form
of an adaptation of another folk tale from One
Thousand and One Nights. Aside from that, though,
everyone's still very much
in the dark on this one.
Before Bad Boys for Life had even hit theaters in
early 2020, Sony was already prepping the fourth
installment in the Bad Boys franchise. Bad Boys
4 was announced in January 2020 as a follow-up to
the first three films in the hit buddy cop action
franchise, which first kicked off in 1995 with the
original Bad Boys. Starring Will Smith and Martin
Lawrence, that original movie follows two Miami
detectives as they investigate a case of stolen
heroin while protecting the witness to a murder.
Bad Boys was successful enough to earn
a sequel, which was released in 2003.
The third movie, Bad Boys for Life, catches
up with Detectives Lowrey and Burnett
17 years later, as they investigate a string
of murders with connections to Lowrey's past.
"Bad boys bad boys, whatcha gonna do, whatcha
gonna do when we-" "Hey, hey, ah ah, no. Never."
No plot details have yet been revealed about the
fourth film, but the script is being penned by
Chris Bremner, who also worked on Bad Boys
for Life. While nothing is official yet,
it's also safe to assume that Smith and
Lawrence will both return for part four.
Here's hoping it doesn't take
another 17 years to release.
Despite having a pretty definitive ending,
the Oscar nominated Queen flick Bohemian
Rhapsody may be getting a sequel. The first film
portrays the early days of the iconic group,
from its unsteady beginnings in 1970
when Farrokh Bulsara first joined,
through the next few decades, as Bulsara changes
his name to Freddie Mercury, rises to fame, and
eventually splits up the group in the early '80s.
Bohemian Rhapsody ends with the band reuniting for
Queen's performance at Live Aid in 1985, before
explaining how Mercury died of AIDS in 1991.
There's no word yet on what the plot of Bohemian
Rhapsody 2 could be, whether it would delve
into the last six years of Mercury's life, or
whether it would follow the other members of
the band after his death. In a post on Instagram
Live in 2021, Queen guitarist Brian May said:
"It's going to be hard to follow [Bohemian
Rhapsody] as none of us could have predicted
how massive that was going to be. [...] But
yes, we are thinking maybe it could happen,
but it would have to be a great script. It's
going to take a while to figure that out."
But as far as whether the band has
interest in a sequel, May said:
"We are looking at it. Yeah,
we have been looking at ideas."
While 2021's Cruella was set up to serve
as a prequel to Disney's animated film
One Hundred and One Dalmatians, by the time
the end credits rolled, it was clear that there
is plenty more of Cruella's story to tell.
Sure enough, Cruella 2 is now in the works,
which will see Emma Stone returning to the
role of Estella and her ruthless alter ego,
Cruella de Vil. Also coming back is director
Craig Gillespie and writer Tony McNamara,
although none of Stone's fellow Cruella cast
members are yet confirmed for the sequel.
The first film saw aspiring fashion designer and
petty criminal Estella scheming her way to the top
of the fashion industry and usurping the reign
of reigning fashion queen Baroness von Hellman.
By the end of the film, Cruella has claimed the
Baroness' empire as her own and fully embraced her
dark and semi-villainous persona. Yet she still
has a great love of dogs, particularly Dalmatians,
which begs the question of just how she transforms
into the kind of person who wants to skin them
for her coats. Perhaps we'll find out when
Cruella 2 eventually struts into theaters.
Producer and director Phil Lord has said
that the team behind the Jump Street movies
is putting a pin in 23 Jump Street, which
would mark the third outing for Channing Tatum
and Jonah Hill. However, the studio is moving
forward with a spinoff of the comedy franchise,
this time focusing on a female crime-fighting duo.
The first two Jump Street films follow
a pair of male cops who go undercover at
educational institutions in order to
ferret out elusive drug suppliers.
Presumably, the plot of Jump Street: Now For
Her Pleasure would be much in the same vein.
It will also probably exist in the same universe
as the existing Jump Street films, functioning
as a continuation of the story started by officers
Morton Schmidt and Greg Jenko in the first movies.
This time, the stars taking the fight to the
streets will be Tiffany Haddish and Zendaya, who
will most likely be playing undercover narcotics
officers, similar to Tatum and Hill's characters
in the first two movies. After directing the first
two Jump Street films, Chris Miller and Phil Lord
will be stepping aside for this third outing,
with Rodney Rothman taking the director's chair.
Rothman will also be collaborating on the script
with Bob's Burgers writers Lizzie and Wendy
Molyneux. Rothman previously helped write the
screenplay for 22 Jump Street, and co-directed
Lord and Miller's acclaimed animated film
Spider-Man: Into the Spider-Verse. Sadly, there's
been no word yet on what the plot will entail — or
whether Schmidt or Jenko might make an appearance.
Sylvester Stallone and The Expendables 4 have
been engaging in a will-they-won't-they dance for
a few years now, but it's finally official: The
muscle-bound gang is getting back together again,
with Scott Waugh directing and
Spenser Cohen writing the script.
In addition to Stallone, the Expendables
franchise has been a veritable who's who
of current and former action superstars,
featuring everyone from Mel Gibson to
Bruce Willis to Jean-Claude Van Damme to
Chuck Norris and many, many, many more.
"I'm back!"
This time around, we know that Stallone
and Jason Statham are coming back,
as are Dolph Lundgren and UFC legend
Randy Couture. A number of other stars,
including Megan Fox and 50 Cent, have also
signed onto the film in undisclosed roles. Plus,
the former holder of the World's Strongest Man
title, Eddie Hall, has personally been offered
a role by Stallone himself. Hall will play a
villain, as will martial arts star Iko Uwais,
who will apparently be facing off
against Statham's character in the film.
Of course, these are still early days for
the project, so don't be surprised to see
more Expendables veterans return…
and a few other fresh faces, too.
After the massive commercial success of Disney's
photo-realistic remake of The Lion King,
it seemed like only a matter of time
until a sequel was announced. However,
the director taking the directorial reins
from Jon Favreau for The Lion King 2
is probably not a name most people would
have expected to hear: Barry Jenkins. This
Academy Award-winning writer and director is
best known for creating critically-acclaimed
dramas with strong racial themes, including
Moonlight and If Beale Street Could Talk.
Jenkins won't be writing The Lion King 2, but
he'll be working from a script by Jeff Nathanson,
who also penned the first Lion King. While no
specific details of the plot have been revealed,
we know that it will act as a prequel to
the first film, following Mufasa and Scar
in their younger years. It will also
introduce a number of new characters,
though who they are and what animals
they might be has yet to be confirmed.
Although The Lion King 2 seems like
an outlier in Jenkins' filmography,
the director sounds excited about
working on the sequel for Disney, saying:
"Having the opportunity to work with Disney on
expanding this magnificent tale of friendship,
love and legacy while furthering
my work chronicling the lives and
souls of folk within the African
diaspora is a dream come true."
Some films get theatrical or streaming sequels
while others get turned into TV series,
but if you're the Nicolas Cage series National
Treasure, you get both. The long-awaited threequel
to 2004's National Treasure and 2007's National
Treasure: Book of Secrets seems to finally be
moving forward at Disney, tapping Bad Boys
4 scribe Chris Bremner to write the script.
But that's not all; National Treasure will
also find new life as a Disney+ TV series,
which producer Jerry Bruckheimer says
is currently in the development process.
While National Treasure 3 is expected to reunite
the cast from the first two films, including
Cage himself, the TV series will follow a young
woman named Jesse, who embarks on an adventure
to uncover a lost Pan-American treasure. Serving
as one of the executive producers for the series
is Jon Turteltaub, who helmed both of the first
two films and is expected to direct the third.
Although the Disney+ series is currently further
along in the development pipeline, with production
set to start in early 2022, Bruckheimer says he's
hopeful that both projects will ultimately come
to fruition, delivering a veritable treasure
trove of new National Treasure adventures.
With the open-ended conclusion of the 2020
Charlize Theron action hit The Old Guard,
it seemed as though the film was begging for a
sequel. Sure enough, The Old Guard 2 is in the
works for Netflix. The sequel will bring back
star Charlize Theron as Andy, the millennia-old
mercenary who, in the first film, realized
her immortality was finally beginning to wane.
Also returning will be Marwan Kenzari and Luca
Marinelli, who played Joe and Nicky, respectively,
the life partners for centuries who
also act as part of Andy's group.
Production is set to start in the first quarter
of 2022, with Victoria Mahoney attached to direct,
and while no plot details have been released yet,
the first film set up some
intriguing possibilities.
After betraying the other members of their group
and being punished with a century of exile,
the devious Booker comes face to face with Quynh
, played by Veronica Ngo. Quynh is a former member
of their immortal squad who they had thought
was lost forever at the bottom of the ocean.
"I feel her pain, her rage. She feels crazy."
Although Quynh used to be Andy's closest ally,
centuries of drowning over and over might just
have changed her tune. This intriguing story
thread will hopefully be followed up when The
Old Guard 2 hits Netflix sometime in the future.
Mere days after the 2021 Chris Pratt sci-fi action
film The Tomorrow War dropped on Amazon Prime,
Amazon Studios and Skydance were
already talking about a sequel.
The first film centers around Pratt's
character, who's recruited as a soldier
to travel to the future and fight a war to save
humanity. The sequel would reportedly bring back
Pratt and the first movie's main cast, along
with director Chris McKay and writer Zach Dean.
The Tomorrow War earned an enthusiastic
reaction from Amazon Prime subscribers,
who viewed it enough for it to debut as the
number one film across streaming platforms
over the July 4th holiday weekend. So
it's no wonder that the studios would
be eagerly circling a sequel — although
no specific plans are confirmed yet.
And while we don't yet know what the story
of a potential The Tomorrow War 2 would be,
it will hopefully be just as thrilling
and action-packed as the first film.
The long-running Insidious franchise
is getting a fifth installment,
and this time, franchise star Patrick Wilson
will be settling into the director's chair.
The first two films follow a couple whose
young son is haunted by otherworldly beings,
while the third and fourth are prequels
that focus on the psychic who aided the
heroes of the first two films. Insidious 5
will follow the son from the original movie,
now a decade older, as he heads
off to college. In a statement
regarding his directorial duties
on the fifth movie, Wilson said:
"I'm honored and thrilled to be at the
helm of the next Insidious installment,
which will provide an amazing chance to unpack
everything the Lamberts went through a decade ago,
as well as deal with the consequences of their
choices. [...] Into the further we go..."
"The further" that Wilson is referring to is
the demonic realm that houses the entities which
haunt the characters in the Insidious films. The
script for Insidious 5 was penned by Scott Teems
and based on a story by Leigh Wannell, who
wrote the first four films in the franchise.
Although the original Tron wasn't much
of a hit when it was released in 1982,
the movie developed a growing cult following in
the decades that followed, which ultimately proved
big enough to warrant a sequel. Tron: Legacy
premiered in 2010, starring Garrett Hedlund,
Olivia Wilde, and original Tron star Jeff
Bridges. Tron: Legacy did well enough to
earn a sequel of its own, and It Runs in
the Family writer Jesse Wigutow was brought
aboard in 2012 to pen the script. However,
Disney reportedly couldn't figure out how to
best approach a new installment in the Tron
series, and so the project was put on hold.
Now, the third Tron film now appears to be
moving forward again, with Lion director Garth
Davis coming aboard to direct and Jared Leto
attached to star. While Davis is not known for
the type of big-budget, CGI-heavy filmmaking that
a Tron film would require, insiders say that he
fought hard for the job, eventually convincing
Disney executives that he was the right person
to bring the Grid back to life. As for Leto, he
may have inadvertently revealed the title for
the third Tron in a now-deleted tweet confirming
his casting, referring to the film as Tron: Ares.
Although the project has yet to receive a
green light, Davis' and Leto's involvement
may signal a light at the end of the
tunnel for this long-gestating threequel.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.